I I think probably where things are
headed from uh the standpoint of AI is
that we have a silicon shortage now that
will transition to a voltage Transformer
shortage in about a year ironically
Transformers for
Transformers you need you need
Transformers to run Transformers
somebody has a sense of humor in this
thing I think
yes oh man fate loves
irony ironic humor and an ironically
funny outcome seems to be often what
fate wants humor is all you need I think
spice is all you need somebody
posted yeah but yeah so so we're we're
have a silicon shortage today um a
voltage Step Down Transformer shortage
probably in about a year and then just
electricity shortages in general in
about two years I I gave a speech for
the sort of world Gathering of utility
companies electricity companies um and I
I said look you really need to prepare
for a tribling of electricity demand um
because all transport is going to go
electric with the ironic exception of
rockets and uh and and heating um will
also go
electric um so energy usage right now is
roughly 1/3 very rough terms 1/3
electricity 1/3 transport 1/3 heating um
and so in order for everything to go
sustainable to go electric um you uh
need to Triple electricity output so I
encourage the utilities
to uh build more power plants and and
also to probably have well well not
probably they should definitely buy more
batteries because the the grid currently
is sized for Real Time load which is
kind of crazy CU you know that means you
got to size for whatever the the peak
electricity demand is like the worst
second or the worst day of the year or
you can have a brown out or
blackout and you we had that crazy
blackout for several days in in in
Austin
um so uh
because there's almost no buffering of
energy in the grid like if you've got a
Hydro power plant you can buffer energy
but otherwise um it's all real
time so with batteries you can
you can produce energy at night and use
it during the day so you can
buffer so I I I expect that there will
be very heavy usage of of batteries in
the
future because the peak to trough ratio
for power plants is anywhere from 2 to 5
you know so it's like lowest point to
highest point so like batter is
necessary to balance it out and then but
the demand as you're saying is going to
grow grow grow grow yeah and part of
that is the compute
yes yes I mean electrification I mean
electrification of Transport uh and and
electric heating will will be much
bigger than AI at least in the short
term in the short term um but but even
for for AI you you really have a growing
demand for electricity for electric
vehicles and a growing demand for
electricity for to run the computers for
AI mhm and so this is obviously leading
going to lead to a electricity
shortage